Дякую Олексій Гончаренко європейська
Солідарність Я хочу колеги поділитися з
вами дуже поганою історією яка зараз
відбувається в місті Одесі в моєму
рідному місті Справа в тому що в місті
Одесі як в багатьох інших містах України
діє Волонтерський центр Гончаренко центр
таких міст більше 20 по всій державі ми
всі Працюємо як багато хто з вас на нашу
перемогу волонтери Ми допомагаємо в
Одесі цей центр є одним з найбільших
виробників в Україні маскувальних сіток
камуфляжу за рік вторгнення 45 000 м²
маскувальних сіток десятки автомобілів
дрони підтримка вимушеним переселенцям
всім добро і саме головне допомога ЗСУ
все це відбувалося в цьому приміщенні аж
раптом коли моя активно почав ставити в
тому числі в Одеській облраді питання що
заступник голови Одеської облради від
партії опзж Комаровський який називав
тероборону бандою є Прямо та конкретною
п'ятою колоною Кремля має бути прибраний
з посади заступника голови Одеської
обласної ради навколо нього утворилася
коаліція слуг народу На жаль і опзж які
разом його залишили на посаді далі
незаконно тримають платять зарплату в
нас нема грошей для військовослужбовців
для шкаровського таких як він його водія
секретарки для всіх гроші є але далі
почали мститися і Одеська обласна рада
незважаючи на те що є договір оренди
цього приміщення викидає волонтерів
сьогодні з цього приміщення маскувальні
сітки не потрібні допомога ЗСУ не
потрібна нічого не потрібно присилають
тітушню і в найкращих традиціях діють
друзі На жаль ми це бачимо по всій
Україні а так і на волонтерів А так і на
всіх тих хто намагається все зробити для
нашої Перемоги сьогодні невже це
прийнятно я звертаюсь до колег зі слуги
народу Ну у горизонте в своїх
представників в Одеській області що вони
попутали кого вони там чекають Вони
чекають Путіна Вони чекають кого І нащо
вони такі речі роблять ще не пізно це
зупинити повернути волонтерів протягнути
руку підтримки і працювати разом в
єдності на перемогу або якщо ваша
єдність це з опзж Так скажіть чесно
людям про це наша єдність опзж нас інші
цілі і рухаємось ми в інші напрямок Ну
тоді будьте чесними з людьми тож Я
закликаю вас закликаю президента
закликаю відреагувати на себе предел
захистити волонтерів в Одесі в Києві у
Львові в Дніпрі всюди тільки так
переможемо волонтери ЗСУ - перемога
Слава Україні
[музика]